what's up recheck nation I am Sean
Humphrey and I'm Greg Alva so today we
are going to be talking about DC's
Captain Marvel I am super excited about
this because I actually not to brag or
anything the hell are you what who are
you how did you get into her apartment
where's Craig what do you mean where's
Greg I'm right here
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my bad
sorry about that we're gonna talk about
Shazam today you you let a little boy
into our apartment yeah but he was the
funny bit the bits not even accurate
it's not like Shazam shrinks into Billy
Batson
yes he does Billy shout Shazam and he
turns it this Shazam yeah but it's not
like Bruce Banner morphing into the Hulk
like why couldn't even warn his own
clothes cuz it was funny you shouldn't
make little kids wear your clothes look
a film this review or not who the hell
was that kid
you guys catch that bit of white cream
on my beard can't notice all these
things when you're filming one of these
videos thing anyway Aragorn Jones was
actually that person who played the
young version of me he has his own
YouTube channel you guys should go check
it out he does reactions on there as
well big thanks to err ignore first stop
it on bye he's a family friend not just
some kid also big thanks to Kyle either
man from fan theory TV for putting
together a little bit of VFX for us
you're the best buddy go check out his
youtube channel as well onto a review
for Shazam for anyone who's been
following our reactions to this you'll
know I have heavily been anticipating
this comic adaptation for quite some
time I read the Shazam graphic novel
society monsters of evil and I also read
from the new pages of the 52 that Geoff
Johns edition there's a person who read
the comics I really liked this movie a
hell of a lot especially because it
seemed to kind of combine both elements
especially cuz I wasn't expecting this
movie to have as much horror elements
infused throughout that was like
sprinkled in here Shazam's are a rather
bright comic book and then the Rhian
dition with the new 52 from Geoff Johns
that one is much darker in its tone and
this seem to have like the right blend
especially when you're borrowing fanatic
elements and tones from movies like big
they seem to strike the right balance
which I thought surprisingly were sort
of hearkened back those like Amblin
entertainment kind of horror where it's
not like a scary movie but you got seams
you're like that is surprisingly
horrific I remember that even in adult
form your protagonist is ostensibly a
kid it heightens that level attention
and with David F Sandberg in the
director's seat I feel yeah it's a very
conscious decision because he is able to
play up the horror especially when the
villainy of the movie sets in and I
thought this movie was a lot of fun
easily DC's most fun movie ever and I
laughed quite a bit we weren't sitting
right next to each other so I don't know
if you were laughing but I there were
times where I was like cracking up very
very hard in this film the thing that
should matter the most and was to me the
best part of the film was Zachary Levi a
Shazam yeah the first act of this movie
it's fine the movie really kicks into
high gear once you get into Act two
where
you know a sure angel is able to morph
into Zachary Levi a Shazam once that
plot line that you've seen the trailer
kicks and the movie becomes a total
blast from here on out his boyish like
charm and personality at first I was
wondering if it might be contradictory
to the performance at a sure angel was
given because they were the you know the
same characters watching the movie
you're like okay I get it that is the
way he views himself as Shazam it's the
kind of way you know even today as a guy
in his late 20s if I were to have the
ability to morph into a superhero I
would probably have the kind of attitude
that's accurately why Shazam was having
in this movie well yeah for a lot of the
movie I mean the stuff that you do with
Billy just as himself is kind of the
heavier more serious stuff because he is
kind of a troubled at risk here he's
looking for his actual family and
whatnot so when he's in Shazam mode that
is at least for the first part of the
movie some of the times where he gets to
be the most carefree and just have fun
as a character which is kind of neat
because yeah it really capitalizes on
Zachary Levi's natural charm and then
when you know the stakes actually start
to set in he's good at that stuff to
Jack Dillon grazier who we know from the
movie it's their gazebos he plays
Freddie Freeman in this film part of the
foster family that Billy Batson is a
part of in this movie and they
essentially become like best friends
because they're brothers now and for me
I thought whenever he was on-screen he
practically stole the show or he was
exactly on par with Zachary Levi
wouldn't they have scenes together they
are undoubtedly the best moments out of
the whole movie I've heard of it too
yeah there's a whole foster family in
here which is essentially the heart of
the movie which I'm really ready and and
Billy are really the core of it yeah
Freddy's the one who like walks him
through being a hero and he's the one
who's like really nerdy and into all
this stuff who kind of brings like a
scream esque element into the movie or
like a Deadpool the way it's constantly
pointing out superhero tropes and using
that from meta angle and stuff like that
yeah it really drives that the movie has
a lot of self-awareness and so with the
superhero genre there's some bits that I
would love to go into and a spoiler talk
and there's just some story beats that I
would love to go into in a spoiler talk
there there are some very like it's not
exactly Deadpool but
kind of teetering there a little bit who
would something with some of the moments
that they have very self-aware in terms
of the structure yeah yeah definitely
the action in this movie is is cool it's
not like anything that we really haven't
seen before honestly but it's not really
about that one thing I really appreciate
about this movie is bringing back a
sense of wonder with superheroes so when
he is discovering his powers he starts
to discover like new things he can do so
much fun to be had there because it's
not like oh cool epic action scene
whenever he does something new you're
like oh that is pretty good like the way
they're reacting to it you're not really
expecting it in that moment that when it
happens you are kind of filled with this
sense of joy yeah I feel like what makes
the action in this particular movie
distinct is yeah not that it's
necessarily shot with the utmost prowess
that we've never seen in one of these
movies but it is also again the context
of just how the characters are reacting
to it because so much of the time it's
about Billy sort of discovering the
limits and yeah the extension is power
and so there is like a character
reaction within that that makes it a lot
of fun and makes the action itself a
journey and I think the whole plotline
were most of Zachary Levi Shazam is at
without spoiling anything I really
thought it was a unique direction to get
especially with so many superhero movies
nowadays the exploration they did with
his character and how he's sort of the
kind of person he's evolving into before
he even confronts dr. sivana in this
movie I thought was really wonderful and
it was it that to me was the biggest
breath of fresh air was a unique kind of
exploration with being a superhero yeah
and that was something I was wondering
from what I do know about the comic how
they were gonna handle coming into this
and I did like that they made Billy
really have to have a character arc and
earn the power that he felt given over
time and it is felt and it is a family
film overall and a holiday yeah I was
thinking like what Dave is probably
cause it like the you know the blu-ray
release or something mark Strong is dr.
sivana I think Mark Strong does a good
job I think he's effective there's a
couple of elements in here that nothing
I don't really like dislike there's
things I just kind of him like I don't
neutral or don't really care about in
this movie I think everything that I
really liked about this movie truly
stands out for me and filled me with a
lot of emotion you know and then there's
some things where I'm like
I appreciate all the things they were
going for here like with Savannah and
there's a point in the movie where I'm
like oh is this half his movie - you
know who they're the way they're setting
up this film so I like that they gave a
lot of characterization to our villain
they gave a lot of backstory I thought
was really cool on paper but there was I
can't quite pinpoint her right now
there's something about it where I just
kind of didn't find it fully effective
even though they're given all this
backstory I still don't feel the stakes
with it his character power-wise sure he
matches with Shazam there's never really
that sense of danger attention not that
this movie necessarily needed it but I
also kind of think it could have
benefited from it you know I was saying
something to make his presence a bit
more distinct because while they do
offer you some understandable insight
into the character I feel like what Mark
Strong is physically given to work with
on screen is kind of a lot of what we
see him do in this kind of role a lot of
the time or other actors yeah so like
he's good at it yeah and the character
is kind of cool and distinct but
ultimately not necessarily one of the
most memorable or effective villains I
can't tell if that's the point
especially with the jokes they make like
you see the chair was like oh you're bad
guy like that joke I felt like they did
more with him than I expected them to do
even though the man is such a big part
of this Shazam comics yeah especially
where the movie starts ah yeah but
there's something about there was
there's a lack of effect there's also
some VFX in here which sometimes look
cool and it would be spoiler territory
to really go into it there sometimes it
looks cool but then there are other
times where it does look pretty cheesy
like floating heads on completely
different bodies there's like other
character I can't go into it there's
other characters in here where I was
like it looks cool and then times just
looks very cheesy but the thing that
makes up for it is this film has a lot
of intentional cheese yeah so because of
that I'm not like stupid apparently
inappropriate in this movie yeah with a
sure angel I kind of flip-flop with his
performance on this movie I feel like
Zachary Levi and Jack Dylan grazier are
like way up here a sure angel I can feel
the notes he was going she was trying to
hit basically I didn't always feel it
being as lived-in as the other
characters kind of like Captain Marvel I
feel like you get one you get one really
good scene where a sure angel has to
really act and have
yeah the impact of a dramatic weight but
a lot of the allure and a lot of the
most impression you get is from his time
spent as Shazam and so I do feel like
this movie maybe could have used just a
couple more like they do a good job of
cluing unit backstory making you feel
for him but in kid mode I maybe would
have liked to have seen one or two more
personal moments you're alright if you
guys have seen that my trailer reaction
I'm not gonna confirm what theories came
true or what didn't come true
some did some didn't I think it's the
most fun of the DC film and as a whole
Wonder Woman third act it's a lot of
crap I still prefer Wonder Woman over
this movie if I had to yeah it's good
it's just got a bigger impact yeah I
think as a whole film this is probably
the best of the current iteration of the
DCU yeah I mean is I think it's the most
easily enjoyable it's the most
heartwarming it's the most sort of fun
and there's also a lot more supporting
characters in this film that get a lot
more attention they might realize from
the trailers were happy to believe and
there's just some really great comedic
direction in this movie I had a really
good time and do highly recommend this
movie check it out didn't blow my mind
but I had a great time alright guys what
we're gonna the people who got to see an
advanced screening of Shazam tell us
what you thought if you haven't seen it
yet who do you already want Shazam to
team up with in the DC Universe comment
below you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Bell
check us out on patreon and make sure to
check out Eragon drones here in car army
on their channels thanks guys
you